good morning everyone good morning
Millennials so you like it again I don't
know I just don't know what else to say
I find the introduction to the show
extremely uncomfortable I love it happy
Tuesday everyone it is a beautiful
summer's day in New York City and
wherever you're from and I'm wearing
fishnets oh and we match wears yes Oh
America so you must open we're so proud
to be an American oh no realized that
like we always say like the people who
listen to our show are like so unique
and so special and so smart and like
like have good jobs like they're just
like they're good people and like you
know what I've become to realize like
there are some people who watch our show
who could be like our big break then we
have a lot of listeners who like worgen
TV we're gonna do more can use 'ok so
i'm gonna use every opportunity as like
an audition have you not been doing that
anyway happily now I'm consciously
thinking of a big time magazine editor
could be watching our show I'm proud to
be an American where at least I know I'm
free or a big music exec right so you
would be doing things differently than
what you've been I'm just more aware now
of my skin like my talents yeah and I
just want to hone them so that like this
is basically one big audition okay let's
not put that the other day well I'm
rooting for you you guys before we jump
in to today's show I need to talk about
the thing that I'm most excited about
I mean hey it's more home slept since
yesterday what time did we have that
call we had that call yesterday like 2
o'clock 3 o'clock I think would be three
o'clock anyway you guys so cam toast
which is a dream that was dreamt up on
the show while we were sitting me
honestly when we thought about it I was
like it's just a pipe dream like that's
like 5 years down the line when the show
like hits the network's like we'll have
the budget like well we could do it but
we just thought we'd put in a call to
like the one person we know who like
runs a cam right and it's a realizable
it's a reality we are working out the
details nothing is set in stone yet and
literally yesterday we were talking
about how we won't count on chickens
before they hatch but here we are like
yeah here we are counting your chickens
and four and a half
we're so excited like we
couldn't stop coming up with ideas no
it's the Moses and Kelly woman someone
putting the best idea that we're doing
but the color where teams are camp our
team Kim versus team Taylor oh I saw
that too but so that's Lydia um I don't
know I was thinking about color war
teams - I knew it has many generals it
has all the pages that we be generals of
our own team no total it has be like the
pink something was worse the green some
things I don't know it'll really come
down to the teams we choose and I don't
I know a lot about the toasters but I do
not know their athletic ability yeah so
basically here's what we have
alternative but we just wanted to put it
out there cuz we wanted people to start
like making boobs like a weekend
available think about the easiest way
for you to get to the Poconos thinking
of the weekend of September 7th it would
be arrive Thursday night and go home
Sunday morning fun-filled activities of
course we're thinking that the whole
weekend will cost each person around
four or five hundred dollars which we
know is a lot so that's why we wanted to
give people some time in advance to
start saving up and it's got to be worth
that includes room and board so once you
show up to camp people not spending any
more money
alcohol meals alcohol everything is
taken care of I totally encourage you to
bring your own snacks and drinks yeah
because you might want some stuff in the
bunk like the Buncombe I'm coming up to
camp but we curly start setting up my
back like the bug is what I'm most
excited for no we should know early
anyway horse I love camp much I do the
toe oh and like the toast will be live
from the rec hall every morning and it's
just gonna be a dream there's gonna be a
talent show of course okay so this camp
that we're renting is a camp we actually
went to camp at and the grounds are like
this really beautiful like camp grounds
that are owned by like this company and
they rented out to like corporate
companies and different camps like all
these different groups so we knew that
the first place we would call is this
camp and in the only place people hug
this doesn't work so many up with where
we're working out we're going to him I'm
not interested in going to someone
else's camp no no make no connection to
they have this big bonfire which
obviously we would do every night and
the concering
the counselor and what they did when we
were at campus every time there's a
bonfire was also a talent show so like
they would get a big speaker and like we
would see them dance and like whatever
other town some you'd totally do that I
kept telling hundred percent I think the
whole time if you play an instrument
bring it we're doing live country music
all weekend like this bring your
instruments bring your chairs like you
know those chairs that you get like for
festivals where like they just
they scratch up and then they sit down
cozy Creek no no they've legs like the
real chair it's like a chair boy beach
chair like everyone has to each chair
I'm bringing home with the leg rests in
the cup holder mm maybe a little heating
pad I think I'm gonna bring a beanbag
like it's gonna be so epic and like I
just want it to be amazing so that we
can that I start doing it like twice a
summer oh my god I would it's my dream
Jackie same and then more than that
we'll have like waterfront ropes course
you know it'll be anyways like all camp
activities but like with the wine in
your hands when we were on the phone the
camp director was like well would you
want like just us to like put a schedule
together of like activities for you guys
like evening activities or just like
you've everyone meals and have everyone
do what they want I'm like no no we want
the full experience like I want to wake
up obviously not as early as Muse to
make up a camp like wait we'll be a
little but I want the whole day wake up
it'll be fine we'll be at 9:00 that's
okay breakfast 9:30 you'll be woken up
to Claudia
singing a crop I'm the microphone on the
star-spangled banner and this is the
thing like the bunks even if you know
someone great you can like you can
request to me in the same Park as your
friend that you're going with but if you
don't know anyone like that's even
better like it'll be so toasty do not
bring your boyfriend's like this is a
girls trip obviously you know like and
we can't discriminate against genders
and we don't we go
but you'll bring your boyfriend so bring
your like straight guy friends like it's
not for them you know um this is what's
getting me through now and this is like
my motivation super late for breakfast
I'm like we need to be sponsored by PD
yeah anyways details to come
keep that weekend open start saving up
start getting excited and well we'll let
you know more as we know it I have I
have a follow-up call today and I'll let
you know the deets
no I'm truly dead no it's the best idea
live off my favorite part is that like
well because this would be our first one
like we'd have to have a video
videographer coming like shoot some
b-roll and stuff so then we can make
like a camp video for next year like the
morning so the camp promotion I mean the
testimonials of yeah by the water yes oh
my god oh my god you guys it's gonna be
everything and a lot of people are
saying that they're pregnant and they
don't know if they should come arguing
people can definitely go pregnant people
are more than welcome
obviously you can't drink an like you'll
be limited in your activities but you
should definitely be there go on it like
it's relaxed I guess well yeah we're
like
a nice long walk around the ground
unless literally I would wear Sophie
Shore it's like legit like back in the
day no I'm I'm gonna make a uniform and
like people that's more work but people
could order uniforms from us
that'll be separate pricing but you know
if you want to get them toasty or just
wear whatever the hell you want cuz
literally there's like no boys just
don't worry it's gonna amazing we're not
only makeup the whole time I mean I'm
probably where I want just like ever
since we have we like really like
brothers I mean all these toasters said
I've been dying to meet like I'm going
to wear makeup now that we've like had
this idea like actually come like as a
real possibility like it's all I can
think about no I know and I won't stop
until it's here and like every day I'm
gonna come up with a new idea to make it
even better like this is this is what
I'm so excited what it'll be just the
best weekend of Our Lives like no doubt
like fun in the Sun toaster vibes
drinking like everyone like we're the
most famous people they're like great
but also like I just think it's like a
business move I think this is truly
revolutionary I agree I don't think any
like influence or any auto brand could
ever pull something off like this
except the toast for sure but we're
counting our chickens before they hatch
so we need to stop talking about it stay
tuned to the weekend of September 7th
there is we can't move it so if it
doesn't work for you we will see you
next year yeah she's awesome er and I'm
really sorry about that and maybe we'll
do it in the spring but I saw something
yes babe like I didn't seen in a while
I'm like when we were like saying bye to
each other sick have a good summer I'm
like alright I guess I'm not seeing you
like it was like a really like like wait
what's weird about you four hold on just
a second if yeah but like more think
hold on like those people who like
things like well the world's gonna end
so who cares like what do you call those
d-ball it's like I read another book
once it's like something it starts with
a TR an F I don't know like people who
are just like well world enjoy anyway so
who cares oh I don't like a mentality
they call themselves oh I don't know
them I don't know maybe someone will
write what it is anyways are you ready
to get into the fast night real I need
someone to tell me the name okay it's
like oh it just was at the tip of my
tongue a pessimist no it's like a
fatalist fatalist thank you so took a
fetal Juli Lundy
thank you such like a fatalist thing to
say like
I'll never see you again that's not a
date that you like I just thought it was
a weird thing summer just started three
days ago I was like have a good summer I
guess we're not hanging out for summer
well at least she was honest and I know
he probably didn't want to hang out with
her thanks girl yeah you're off the hook
I was now you're off the table that
summer I know okay we are ready to get
into the fast hi stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast and
before you start getting excited about
camp toast
first up LuAnn de Lesseps acted like the
biggest diva during Pride Parade
apparently this story is so she was a
grand marshal of the San Francisco Pride
Parade of him yes right LuAnn de Lesseps
wrote in San Francisco's Pride Parade on
Sunday with a group that was voted quote
most outrageous but we hear the countess
could have also won biggest diva Delos
Epps who was in town to perform her
cabaret show rode with Emperor
Leandro Gonzales and drag queen Empress
Polo Del Mar for lgbtq profit the
imperial council but a spy said the Real
Housewives star was barking orders the
entire parade she was yelling at an
associate who was then yelling at
volunteers 3m who three of whom were
deaf the source added she was very
concerned with people recognizing her
she completely stressed volunteers out
by micromanaging about a banner
announcing her presence interesting so
she wanted people to know she was or she
didn't I think she did apparently she
kept calling people over to her vehicle
which you can't do her contingent was
yelled at numerous times by security
because they kept pulling people in from
the audience that also mental that's a
secure ride when slow to well yeah have
you ever been in a parade everything
moves slow yes if I see an exception I
just feel like of all the prides to be
invited to San Francisco's definitely
prestigious cuz it's like a GB TQ like
city and I just think like it's just an
honor to be to be asked to sit on in a
car and I just think she should totally
defecated on it you think so I just feel
like like parades are hectic she's
overwhelmed like I don't think you're
under the hot Sun I don't think you can
help it be a diva but I just think like
all LGBTQ icons are like divas like Lady
gaga
they wouldn't tell me again she was
playing into her like icon role totally
I'm not gonna have like some low
maintenance like salt of the earth look
at me
every person who's like a like a big
advocacy vana problem she's totally a
demon like everybody yeah every person
who's like a real advocate for ally for
the gay community is a huge diva and
then of themselves so I just think LuAnn
just wanted to fit in I agree and you
know what I think this is like wait are
you trying to meet that we have
housewives named LuAnn and Liam I
thought of that one that's weird I guess
yeah what if there are some there there
have been over a hundred housewives like
it makes sense that aren't their names
start to get similar of all the
housewives who you think deserved like a
second chance
back on the show who's not [ __ ] no
longer on um this is gonna be a
controversial answer I think I know
you're gonna say let's say on the count
of three wait hold on I want to just
make sure it's what I want to say okay
just because now I can't think of
anything else one two three crazy Oh
Brandi Glanville no Carlton Gebbia I
thought right after she was kicked off I
didn't understand why she was but now
she just went through a divorce so like
yes she has too much going on it's too
real for me yeah Brandi Glanville is
insane some point she it's like she's
like the Jill Zarin of the west coast at
some point it's looming she will come
back just when they get desperate like
to make it like a big spectacle I agree
and like even though she's like so crazy
and some of the things that she does did
like I don't agree with she wasn't my
favorite housewife whatsoever like she
brought like so much to Beverly Hills
housewives and like no one could get
away with anything while she was there
like you can smoke hot in Amsterdam I'm
gonna call you out for and like now they
all are like they're all like too smart
and they protect each other and they
don't want to get their hands dirty but
Brandi no matter how big she gets like
we'll always be down to get her hands
right so just like a little scary but
it's also what they need that's so true
they really all protect each other
because like they're so comfortable now
that's kind of what least over and I was
saying in that interview like nobody is
accountable that's so true yeah and like
the ones who've been there on for so
long know exactly how to play it so that
they stay above the fray the new ones
are like barking for scraps but then
also they're not that desperate like
Teddy and Marie I mean jury to only one
who will kind of go there yeah but she
won't go there against LBP and like if
we really are looking for the takedown
of LVP which Erica Jane has not stepped
up to the plate for any coverage or
someone Brandi Glanville on yes but more
importantly be really
and I do love Carlton Gebbia like she
was a one-hit wonder me too and I think
like her her time on the show is like
this time capsule that like we can never
get back and I don't want to but in the
moment I think she was robbed like I
think she had a really look much more of
an interesting story that we even got
like those parties she threw like with
the witchcraft but yeah that was epic
you know who brought her down who Kyle
no oh well that was not good but no I
meant someone else who who I said she
was looped in with voice and voice it
was like so up elusive at Holmes asked
what she was so uninteresting yeah that
was the two of them just had to scram
yeah but now who I sat and Lisa
Vanderpump really close Lisa Vanderpump
is that type of person where it's like
if you do her a solid like she'll never
forget like that season that what it was
hoisted first season and they that was
finally when Kyle Birchers was like
about to turn on Lisa Vanderpump all the
women were getting against the savanna
bump the only person who stayed her
friend was Jose and Lisa never forgot
Lisa still invites her to every event
she's sometimes on sometimes is on
Beverly Hills every time there's like
event I was like yeah I could say no I
said like as if it's her real name honey
what Joyce Giraud but like Brandi
Glanville gave us voice' totally but
then on the other hand like Lisa
Vanderpump like yes she remembers but
then she doesn't treat Kyle with that
same respect
well because Kyle has disrespected her
choice has never respected her like when
Kyle said Lisa Vanderpump will literally
never ever ever forgive Kyle for saying
that being friends with her is like
playing chess with Bobby Fischer and I
won't ever forget first of all just a
brilliant line like literally a scholar
made that up like it's literally just
brilliant and said you all couldn't be
more true every move is so manipulated
three three moves before you know why I
like Carlton because she's totally who
do you think deserves in a second shake
Oh Jill Zarin also but I think I think
you should have like a bunch of shakes
like I don't feel like I didn't get
enough time with her do you know
anything yeah I feel like I was watching
some old season in Nashville I know I'm
but she was her personal decision to
leave and she had on more than enough
time on the show but she was just really
getting into herself and that's Eileen
Davidson
oh my god if Lauren she if you had told
me that like right now in this woman I'd
be saying I'm miss Eileen Davidson after
her first season I would be like what is
wrong with you
that first season I was like so annoyed
even maybe even the second season it
wasn't until she became friends with
Erika Jayne that she really like got
comfortable she came out of her shell
yeah and like she became like this epic
and she was calling the Savannah from
out on all of her [ __ ] like what keeps
you up at night Lisa like she was really
like an important character and I think
just like she doesn't need the show for
fame and she doesn't need it for her
money because she gets that from her day
job and she like she's a prestigious job
and like I'm sure filming is like
hammering she's like a full-time [ __ ]
job those shows are on like a million
times a week like she's busy but I do
feel like I miss her and I feel like the
network misses her and I feel like
everyone misses her like auntie had her
on that during the medley night yeah 32
stars like she they were they they
didn't feel her presence and they had
her on this season they she had a lunch
like they yes and it was how something
like the digital whatever you like they
feel her presence like yeah it's her
absence is felt they feel what we feel
but I don't think it's happening
speaking of about my page six article to
the right isn't ad firm the Manhattan
collection by Jill Zarin what on the
article about those rugs yeah I start
Kelly Bensimon how the Jill Zarin rug
honestly I feel like it's good quality
I'm sure sarin purposes in Gina's house
is legit as well okay wow what a great
Real Housewives tangen yeah okay justice
for all of those people and if anyone
important is listening as they might be
yeah get on it get on it okay next up
Sarah Hyland defends Ariel winter from
pervs on Instagram okay well she really
needs to be defending her from the Daily
Mail but that's neither here nor there
don't think you can shame Modern Family
star Ariel winter without her on screen
big sister having something to say about
it
winter posted a makeup free dress down
image of her pumping gas with her arms
crossed over the weekend with the
caption honestly the only reason I'm
posting this is because I've never seen
a more accurate picture of myself the
post gained a lot of attention and
generated hundreds of comments from fans
however us like weekly notes that some
of the commenters started writing
inappropriate responses to the pic with
regards to her body
many mentioned the fact that the actress
appeared to not be wearing a bra on the
photo and that her nipples were somewhat
visible we are doesn't even in
discussing right oh my god I just can't
believe that this is music okay sarah
hyland do please winter
it's a short amount of family spoke up
for her sibling to slam the trolls in
the perps to all the pervs commenting on
this post she wrote get off line and get
back to your blow-up doll your creeps
like their relationship is really cute
but there is something going on with
Arielle winter and but it's been going
on for long enough now that it's like
just her
I just loved she's so interesting like
first of all she's so rich because every
person on that show is just so ready
yeah and so she's like on this hit show
she got a breast reduction at the age of
18 she emancipated herself from her
parents like she just has like an
interesting background yeah she's always
on the Daily Mail yeah and I don't know
it's like that's their call or she's in
on it like is it a publicist or is it
someone that's doing like Demi Rose
Malby Mel B yeah who do you I can't
that makes no sense at least Ariel
winter is like on occasion so funny
because I used to wake up every day the
first thing I would do is check the
daily mail snapchat story it was just
except I discover story it was probably
10 to 15 stories ranging from
Kardashians to the election tapped right
through those two Demi Moll be like but
I just feel like after I would I was
ready to get up after I watched it the
daily I discovered Channel
it was just the most well-rounded since
the toast and then also they have like
the freaky story and they have the best
pictures and like the murder mysteries
yeah and it's just it's a real testament
it was literally the one thing keeping
me on snapchat I've since left and I
feel like I feel that absence I really I
feel like that's the what we feel for
other people but like where do I get my
news you know where do you get your news
the toast anyways that was just securing
the story oh they are wells and Sarah's
still together
yes but they're not as PDA anymore like
they settled into a normal relationship
Bob yeah or he still isn't nationals
they're not like just together all the
time
yeah but they're really cute but look
what does he do like he's a weekly
podcast
no he's like a radio DJ like radio
personality he actually has a job so he
has to be a bear so every day no
actually I think like he could probably
would make sense to him to tell like he
could do his show for him anywhere and
like it's syndicated so yeah he should
move to LA any time magazine I heard
he's moving to LA who's from a reliable
source and you were there too I was yeah
you probably just weren't paying no I
have to mention
explain to me where were we we were not
gonna say who the person was no because
I know what a potentially so where were
we we were in Nashville cool I
definitely saw something although I
don't really care like where Wales Liz
no but like that's cool that he's like
moving to be with the thing yeah our
Nashville show that was really cute
yeah and he told us what they're gonna
be for Halloween next year but he didn't
say it on the show you probably don't
remember that either
was it yeah yeah yeah it's a good one
you guys well you're such a good memory
I told you didn't say that that's what
I'd say that thing about the plane what
did you claim I said I said I got to
Nashville you're getting her hair done
and I said to you it's so good we and we
both have had an easy flight they said
it's so crazy how you can step onto a
plane and you walk off and you're just
in a different and you're like yes just
in a totally different place I was like
yes it is the reason that I don't even
think that I think that's a loser thing
to think what then you walk into this
little soda can and when you step out of
it you're in a whole new land that it's
crazy no I totally disagree
well you said it I didn't say and that
normally I'd be like oh you were just
agreeing with me to agree with me but
you finished my sentence nope didn't say
it okay moving on
Jamie if I wanted to like get you two
cops or something this would not be the
thing you'd say but now for my my memory
sake didn't say one of us needs to go to
break camp and the other remember one of
the activities our camp to us will be
like brain activities will get like that
guy from that geo to like four not yet
not yet what's that from that the a
brain games yeah that show that would be
he's not that would be really fun yeah
I'll leave it okay
next story is just so crazy and
everyone's talking about it's like
bigger that we should Jersey Shore star
Ronnie ortiz-magro x-gen Harley arrested
for domestic battery their discuss I
don't want to talk about them for sure
and that's right we haven't been talking
about it
but the reason that she got arrested is
so crazy okay listen to this she was
arrested on Sunday people confirms
online records for the Clark County
Detention Center in Las Vegas show that
Harley 31 was arrested for domestic
battery her bail has been set at thirty
three thousand dollars according to TMZ
the two got into a fight while driving
home from a barbeque ortiz-magro 32
reportedly the men
she pull over and let him out of the car
she allegedly took off when he got
caught in his seatbelt dragging her ex
and injuring him while their infant
daughter was a [ __ ] she drags him with
her car they're disgusting and you know
how I feel about Ronnie like I think
he's literally like I'm manipulative
abusive like he's like the exact type of
man we need to completely extinct
eradicate eradicate like but they're
like he is what's wrong with the men in
this world and I don't think it's good
to generalize because there are a lot of
really good men out there but like
there's one brand of man it's called the
Ronnie ortiz-magro type and like they
need to be eradicated like but he makes
me sick to my stomach but she's just as
bad they're honestly they're perfect for
each other
like Sammy was a nice girl she wanted no
part of it's like Jenny hardly even it's
weird by the way that JWoww's name is
Jenny Farley and I get really confused
but this girl's perfect they're perfect
for each other like that's actually
that's a trash does and with the baby in
the car
that's terrible crash why are they still
together
they're prettier for each other that's
why that's true I don't think they
should break up I just I fear for the
child yeah what weird when does Child
Protective Services come in when you're
literally dragging someone with the kid
in the car oh I don't know I'm sure
they're reading this story and wondering
if it's time to jump in
well then in our followers work for CPS
here I feel like the most [ __ ] up
thing you can do is a coffee yes on
someone but it also could be like in the
right situation it's also the best thing
you could do yeah totally but like no I
feel like when like people call like
animal care over Kylie's dog something
too skinny like that's annoying and
that's annoying
yeah like I'm sure they're well fed but
like people like Jenny Harley Farley and
Ronnie ortiz-magro should not be able to
reproduce well they have and that's
actually why they're together
yeah because of reproduction yeah so
that's why they shouldn't be able to
it's horrible look this is disgusting
like I'm really like I honestly you
remember when we China China yeah I'm
officially shiny like we should not be
Ronnie and you should not be making
these people more famous like it's
really disgusting okay so you want to
officially Ronnie and Jen consider
yourselves China wow it's been a while
since he did on it's good there are a
lot of people that we need to turn we've
been like just so lenient okay we trying
to call the interesting drama
yet done so I'm not talking about the
fact that she responded to someone on
Instagram saying you don't know what
goes on in my household mm-hmm and I
just feel like we've started to talk
about the same people a lot peon Ariana
Kristen Tristan and Chloe like we
literally only talk about the same
people every day but say it's been
different so far yeah I'm trying to
switch it up like the show's getting a
little bit on this we need to change it
up but it's not us it's these [ __ ]
celebrities millat everyone hides in
their house and the same five people
step out and do annoying dumb [ __ ] and
call TMZ right and like reply to
people's comments on Instagram but I
love her that's news these days is a
comment on Instagram no I know it's
crazy like that's that's a comments by
celebs situation like enews you did not
need to write it up I totally we can
suffice BIOS on there has to be a line
right like I can't and I shan't anyway
this next story is really sweet cardi B
confirms she's secretly married off set
she released a statement on Instagram
that was really sweet and I feel like
she like when she types on Instagram she
doesn't talk in English but for the most
part this one was pretty much illegible
so she said there are so many moments
that I share with the world and there
are moments said I want to keep for
myself getting married was one of those
moments our relationship was so new
breaking up and making up and we have a
lot of growing to do but we were so in
love we didn't want to lose each other
that's sweet I appreciate and love my
husband so much for still wanting me to
have that special moment that every girl
dreams of when he got down on his knee
and put a ring on my finger and he did
that for me you know like I literally
only wish good things for her DB and
there are a few people who like I
genuinely like even if I like them like
I'll still be like I hate you like I
genuinely love her and I think she's a
good person
I think so too and she's just like she's
making the most out of every opportunity
and she's doing exactly like what you
were I would do if if we were in her
position yeah how did TMZ miss this they
always get the legal docs oh when you
get married it's public record they
weren't looking this was a huge miss
huge miss
and today I googled cardi because I
wanted to know what her real name was
and it says spouse offset married 2017
and I was thinking did that just go up
yesterday or has it been there the whole
time and I was looking for it
I'm gonna guess had it just went up
yesterday but yeah you never know
Google's crazy this is true yeah it's
crazy yeah we have our marriage
certificate we put it oh my god her name
is
Kilis Marlene alabanza and his name is
Chiara Kendrell Cephas and that makes
sense as to why they have pen names
what do you call like not a pen name
station station mm-hmm would your state
name people you have yeah what would
your say go job yeah oh here we are
yeah and our sages how are you
interested there's changes the morning
job I'm going to Chicago on Thursday and
there are 20 VIP tickets left for the
last show on Saturday so if you want to
come people have been DMing me and like
I can't respond to everyone cuz like I'm
so lazy but there are like legit 20
tickets left that's really helpful
also some co-host updates first of all
thank you for all of your suggestions
there about 10 shows this summer that on
the co-host force so I'm gonna be using
that post as a reference Thursday I will
have Darren Karp as my co-host she's the
best I'm so excited I must come up with
a list of questions yeah grab of ash I
literally what I did when she was here
no literally though like she when when I
hung out with her like just on the show
like she reinvigorated like my love for
social media pop culture like Bravo like
she's an wonderful human being I could
use a little bit of that yeah and then
Friday up in the air still but I have
some good things brewing yeah so we're
we're covered yeah we're more than
covered but anyways thank you for all of
your suggestions this story just an
update to yesterday's story that Heather
Locklear was hospitalized after an
overdose call if you follow John John
Twitter he's been really helpful in
aligning the news with the breaking news
with the blinds and what are they saying
that like she's just in such bad shape
and once she got out of prison yesterday
she went back to her house and agreed to
get treatment and then when it was time
to go for treatment she like refused to
go which is why they had to hospitalize
her got it well she was reportedly
hospitalized after a report of an
overdose at her home just hours after
she was released on bail for assaulting
a police officer
Locklear was taken to the hospital
Monday afternoon when paramedics went to
her residence in Thousand Oaks
California after cops received a report
of an overdose according to TMZ the 56
year old actress was arrested for
battery on a police officer Sunday night
just a few days after being released on
a three day psych hold
three-day hold in the psych ward
honestly like this is so sad so sad I
just wanted to give everyone an update
because we were talking about it
yesterday and you know what I put
something on the Instagram and I made
like a mean joke in the caption and then
I changed it cuz I felt bad I saw
I thought it was funny it was okay but
like I didn't know if it was too
insensitive because it was a funny
caption I'm like looking at this picture
of her where she's like so defeated and
I'm like really I'm making jokes
basically what I said Heather Locklear
was arrested for incest but it was
because on the show yesterday that her
relationship with Hilary Duff in the
movie the perfect man where she plays
her mom is weird and then sexual because
she falls in love with her mom online
but I just thought it was too mean and I
literally delete it like the second I
did that was like so embarrassed well
I'm glad I saw it and I'm glad you and
I'm glad you did that yeah that's good
you're learning and you think it was
mean like don't text me no I thought it
was definitely brazen but like you have
big balls like you know and so but like
I'm just so I'm really like so nervous
to like offend people these days that
like I just I'd rather just have a bad
caption and that's fine but I really
when I saw it I was like damn her balls
are huge good for her but that is
literally not times like a good maybe
they're not as big as they're not but
they're still pretty big little saggy
but yeah they're they're actually
compared to the average man's balls
yeah or women they're huge yeah but not
like that Steve I only have one ball but
it's really strong yeah and I love to
make I have a lazy ovary I think no I
just realized that they named a kid
Brady because that's Steve's last name
yeah that is Brady Brady no Britney
Hobbs no but because that's Miranda's
name but when they got married now his
name is Brady Brady Brady Hobbs Brady
yeah no but like when they when they're
in the hospital I she's like I want to
name him Brady Hobbs I'm like selfish
[ __ ]
why isn't he taking his last name and
then I realized that was his last day
I'm like oh my god that's so cute yeah
but then he's Brady Brady and now I
understand how Phillip Phillips was born
yeah his parents were separated when he
was born and then they got back together
okay and I just wanted I had I wanted to
throw in the hell of a clear story but I
just wanted to add one more story
because this is a great segue into
bachelor recap
re line Nick jr. and Lauren Burnham are
officially homeowners they posted a
really cute picture and they're posted a
picture of their home with the with the
address on the back which was really
stupid
yeah but then she deleted it and oh [ __ ]
yeah so it's now it's fine I really like
them I like following them I know people
hate them and I really don't care like I
hope people have the same reaction to
them and I had to like Jourdan and Jojo
like on the show I was like they staying
in the
once they went to real life and I saw
that they actually really liked each
other I'm like okay you know I could
live with it
I really like Aria Morin I think that he
is so hot and I think that she's
literally gorgeous like I just I can't
believe people don't like them like I'm
obsessed with them I'm obsessed with
them too I can understand why people
don't like them but why people didn't
like them but at this point like move on
like Becca who's so wounded like she's
doing fine she talks about him every
episode and if like everything worked
out the way it's supposed to these two
are so cute and they were meant to be
together and if you go rewatch re-season
you'll see the spark between them that i
saw by the way from their date at
bachelor mansion when he took pity on
his telescope situation Chevy I said do
you remember I sat in this chair and I
said when after like the fourth rose
ceremony we're actually starting to have
a breakdown she's like I literally can't
deal with him like dating all these
girls which is we said it's like it when
Shawn B had that reaction like it's so
normal and it's so rare that someone has
that reaction Laurie they get like
infuriated where the person they're
falling in love with his dating like ten
other women like I said I'm like she
she's totally and everything I just
didn't know if it was reciprocated yet
but we caught we totally called it yeah
we weren't sitting in these chairs
actually yes we were no no we weren't we
weren't definitely not but we did call
it okay so go and then he baby honesty
with the toes yes of course I was so and
they stole it but honestly was for a
good cause I will be beyond on it so
remember say do I love her she's a
social she's toaster hurted Sturm
stories are out of control like she what
did she do all day she just works out
all day I know and she's looking good
and I go she looks with me I think she
was in paradise I think she was too
because she worked so hard for that body
for paradise she is literally gorgeous
she never wears makeup
no she's gorgeous and like she's too
pretty for The Bachelor because it's
like unless you're like Saudi eyelashes
extensions like naturally pretty girls
don't fare well on its on the doctor no
but it's like only if you go and get
like micro bladed eyebrows and eyelashes
tensions before annex and hair
extensions and breasts yeah then that's
like the look they're going for and like
a belly button ring yeah no but she's
like always in a bikini cuz she lives in
Miami and she's like literally the most
incredible body no she really has look
I'm jealous of it um I watched her
Bachelorette last night but I watch it
amongst friends so like we didn't
actually watch here are some of the
highlights I know you get free I'm just
like I'm free I watch when I want to but
like I don't feel like I see these
people live tweeting it and they're
trying so hard to be funny because
there's like no material to work with I
just feel low liberté yt-alert a
live-tweeting the bachelor is pulling
teeth I watch it because you guys watch
it and you want us to talk about it
so wait speaking of Twitter literally as
we were sitting here I made the choice
to Twitter because we don't have one and
like I don't know what it's gonna be but
like I just think it'd be fun okay it's
the morning toast because someone has
the morning toast who has it some guy
named Alexander like he has one tweet
from literally six years I feel like you
get it I feel like we could get it too
but for now it's the morning toast just
like our last one was the morning be
yeah and now we just have a southern
twang the more than toast exciting make
sure to follow us for sure here's the
highlights from last night's episode
Colton had his one-on-one really good
FaceTime with Colton like they went
agile following him on Instagram he is
the most attractive guy in the world
delicious they went riding camels and
like it was weird because their camels
like weren't riding near each other so
like they weren't really talking but it
was fine cuz like we don't need Colton
to talk no they went to a hot tub like
in the middle of the desert and it was
cute Pekka was wearing the ugliest
bathing suit I really yeah oh my god her
they went to Vegas this episode and like
her clothes were horrible horrible it
was two looks that were good one after
the dinner after her two-on-one and it
was like with Jordan there was such a
waste because like she said to both of
them home and she just looked amazing
would have been great like for a guy
that she was trying to impress yeah and
then her rose ceremony dress was another
sparkly number and it was very pretty
she is so skinny I got to my friend she
was wearing like this sparkly bomber
jacket like when they first got to Vegas
and it was not good the bathing suit was
not good either then they had their
dinner date and he opened up about being
in love but once before he's with Aly
Raisman
he didn't say her name but he was my god
I forgot he's like I've been in one
relationship and I told her I loved her
and I didn't receive it back home we
broke up and I was like I got a race
when you're a saben there's just so
embarrassing probably reason like she is
so above this in so many ways she's a
world class after she has gold medals at
least they're not dragging her name into
it yeah like they did Aaron Rodgers
right and so and I feel like maybe she
watched she's a fan of the show and now
she's like involved in it and like
that's kind of fun but only if she's a
fan of the show I feel like she's
literally like so prestigious
she took down one of the world's biggest
sexual assaulters like wieners she
spearheaded the attack like I can but
like this is just so shameful I'm sorry
like she does not deserve this I agree
but if anyone was to drag her name
through the mud like I would be happy
that it's called him because like he's
just so beautiful to do it with you know
yeah I feel like ABC is like not above
dragging her into it like I'm surprised
that they didn't they really need the
prestige these days yeah but I think
it's cuz we all know they need the
prestige world I'm surprising it like
when they were doing his package like
show red carpet shots and the two of
them cuz that's like public use anyone
could post them if you just buy them
from Getty no he's so hot like I've been
following him I didn't sir I'm like I
just miss dogs yeah and like I I'm
pretty sure that like him and Tia are
either dating or engaged right now but
if not in like he were to be the
bachelor like I would send Margo on a
plane and of course like right to the
top right to the top like he could be
our brother-in-law and like that's that
would have to be enough but that would
be weird because I'd be sexually
attracted to my brother-in-law
that's true what else happened to one
one between Jordan the model and the
chiller room he was and then she sent
him the chicken on the day portion of
the date which was I thought he won yeah
but I feel like people think that
Jordans like the villain and the chicken
is like the good guy but the chicken is
the instigator and I'm really glad that
Becca saw that because it would have
been so easy to send home like the model
douche 4000 matches on tinder oh really
like professionality and like David was
like Jordan has said in the house that
he feels like he'd be settling for you
and it's very clear that he never said
that like maybe he acted like he can get
hotter girls but he never used the word
settle and like what a horrible thing to
say to someone so mean so she sent David
home then she went on her dinner date
with Jordan who was just showing all of
her model expressions he clearly doesn't
have Botox because his face moves in a
hundred different directions and she
thought like she had to cut him loose
after like putting him through the
wringer and like maybe dance like monkey
style
she had to kind of loose then there was
a group date they went to John Wayne's
house oh that's cool which was cool John
Wayne is old Barry and then like Chris
who started drama on the first night was
starting more drama this night she kept
him around I don't know anything less
attractive than boys who start drama
right it's like here if I were the
Bachelorette these would be my roles
first of all if you're on the two-on-one
date before we even start talking you're
both
because I don't want like obviously
don't like you if I chose you if you
found yourself on a two-on-one date your
trouble goodbye
let me have my day to myself totally
then if you are involved in telling me
about someone else mm-hmm good bye thank
you it's been great knowing you however
on the other hand I feel like she might
like ask your guys it was Wayne Newton
what did I say John Wayne and that's I'm
the lady god I'm sorry
and yes we knew who looks like a piece
of leather really cool he sings that
song that literally makes you cry buddy
Jung [ __ ] again Shan no this is what
they did everyone had to write a song
for Becca of Morris like she's obsessed
with people writing songs for her and
they had to do it to the tune of danke
Schoen so would be like danke Schoen and
they all have to get up and perform it
like cabaret sounds like danke Schoen
that goes really great like I just made
that up it's better what they did but
better than what they did but there was
a lot of danke Schoen I absolutely love
that song Central Park and far how you
tie your dress what a mess I confess
that's not all danke Schoen danke Schoen
yes he looks like he's a Raisin in the
Sun no but when she was on her date with
Colden they took one of those big
double-decker buses and they were riding
down the strip and like an affront and
in the distance there's like a billboard
that says kiss her and begs pointing
they called me she was like look it says
kiss her anything
what did he think like he the show was
horrible like I'm sorry I'm so glad
every time you recap and I'm more and
more solidified in my position of not
watching and I just want you guys to
know I'd do it for you and you're a good
you're good soul and I'm definitely
losing my bracket because leo is still
there for some reason that one with the
long hair like really long hair and I
don't know why and didn't someone come
out oh he's a softcore porn star oh yes
which is you know actually he's better
there's messages right then the rest of
the stuff that's come out about people
honestly like I'm just I'm free I'm free
as a bird I didn't realize Esther day
was Monday like back so in Monday I was
watching power
because I mean [ __ ] love paradise
yeah I love paradise but then it's like
they know that people like love it and
now they just like got carried away like
everything else right when the first two
seasons when I was really like a diamond
in the rough it was like this
experimental thing after bachelor pad
like no one really knew about it was
Clare and Marcus Grant and Lacey Zak
altar calls are who date's Helen Owen
and never forget that he was on the
bachelor and bachelorette I see me
pretends to me above it like that that
bachelor in paradise so that now it's
like gimmicky with the pizza and the
crabs and the bartenders and it's a
little stupid but I liked it the crabs
and the pizza uh anyways it'll be good
and we get to see more of Colton which
just makes yes this pleases me what else
not much we have some good TV do we have
anything on tonight I can never remember
work we're honies on Tuesday or
Wednesday don't know I need to watch the
first episode of Shaw's I didn't hear a
lot about it which makes me sad I didn't
even know it premiered I know that's
Peter did southern charm last week was
good it was it wasn't one of the
bombshell episodes so not much report on
and yeah just gonna keep planning cam
toast really that's all I'm thinking
that's like my shows and cam toast he's
like we're know and I'm like Mad Men can
toast what what I think know that you
have something that weekend
just hold on you're gonna have to move
it everyone hang you're gonna have to
move it and you're gonna have to move it
that's unacceptable
just over looks I'm not worried because
it's being moved was that 9 7 yeah no no
we're good we're good
and you're good the 6th and the fifth
and you know and then I think I have the
whole month of September off great
ok I'll double check except for the
first weekend we were going to camp
toast that's it
so if I've ever heard of one it has been
an absolute pleasure hanging out with
you guys today please remember that the
morning trust is morning money on
Morning Show we're actually now on
Twitter so check out the morning toast
no G in morning if you want to talk
about the Kardashians about show the
housewives just literally anything
except like NATO and North Korea like
head over to the morning totes it's just
it's a fun-filled morning you'll you'll
start your day off at noon which is
great and you'll also start your day off
as a well-rounded individual which is
like what's better than that
nothing literally nothing so make sure
you file the morning to us we're
live-streaming Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook and
on YouTube so make sure you like us on
Facebook and you subscribe to us on
YouTube but if you're not able to take
time out of your day to livestream and
you prefer headphones head over to the
podcast app because this is also
available as a podcast at the morning
toast make sure to leave a subscription
a five star review about how gorgeous we
are and that's all I got for you i'm
claudia a shy girl with no job my
website is backup so make sure to go
over to girl with no job comm for
tickets to all my shows I'll be in
Chicago this weekend and there's a few
tickets left to my sixth show I can't
leave them doing see shows like truly
kill me now I'm so glad to see you all
I'm Jackie I'll show you takeo problem
just feel free to follow me there have a
great day bye
you